the big reveal of playstation service to
compete with xbox game pass could be
right around the corner and gta online
has another way to tug out your wallet
playstation is reportedly going to
reveal its xbox game pass competitor
codename spartacus as soon as next week
according to a new report from bloomberg
the subscription service will combine
playstation now and playstation plus
additionally there will be multiple
tiers within the service that will have
a variety of modern playstation games
and older classic ones the most
expensive tier will reportedly offer
extended demos and game streaming over
the internet the report also notes that
spartacus won't match what's arguably
the most enticing feature of xbox game
pass whereas the latter offers its first
party releases on launch days such as
halo infinite and the upcoming star
field playstation service is not
expected to do the same thing with its
own first party titles like the upcoming
god of war ragnarok last month a report
from venturebeat said that spartacus
would provide three tiers named
essential extra and premium priced at 10
13 and 16 respectively however once the
service is revealed the naming could
potentially change the existence of
spartacus is somewhat of an open secret
with a pre-recorded microsoft video this
week seeing phil spencer state that sony
had already announced its game pass
competitor game pass is a focal point of
microsoft's gaming business with
spartacus seen as a means for sony to
further tap into the lucrative
subscription market and speaking of
subscriptions rockstar games has
announced gta plus a new membership
program launching march 29th on
playstation 5 and xbox series xns that
provides members with access to various
extras and bonuses for six dollars per
month members get an allotment of 500
000 gta bucks every month in their maze
bank accounts as well as discounts on
vehicle upgrades and special cosmetics
however these bonuses will change each
month additionally rockstar announced
that there will be special gta shark
cards available to buy from the
playstation and microsoft stores that
have extra allotment of cash beyond
normal what's more gta plus members will
get exclusive rewards from places like
legendary motorsport maze bank
foreclosures dock teas and other stores
in gta online rockstar also confirmed
that gta online's regular online events
will continue as normal for everyone
regardless of their membership status
now let's go back to playstation news
for a sec because new production images
and even a video from hbo's the last of
us adaptation have been published by
eagle eye fans eurogamer was the first
to notice and scoop up these closer
looks at the show offering the best
looks yet at protagonist joel and ellie
although confirmation that the show
won't be released until sometime 2023
these leaked clips have given fans their
first look at supporting character sam
and henry in the games the characters
are sibling survivors who cross paths
with joel and ellie however their
meeting has a profound effect on ellie
throughout both games are you looking
forward to the last of our show have you
watched the halo show yet let me know in
the comments below